this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history and on this episode he's going
to be taking a look at the weapons of
far cry 2 complete with all the
outrageous jamming and exploding gun
animations
so in this detonation animation the
entire front end of the gun has blown
off
which i don't think is likely if there
are any other games guns and mechanics
that you guys want to see jonathan break
down let us know in the comment section
below
be sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one and if you'd like to help
out the royal army's museum and continue
to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan
all right we have a slight variation on
the 1911 theme here
and it's one of these the star model b
now in the sort of idle uh or opening
animation
we saw the player character thumb the
hammer back
and then manually decock it good start
but then as soon as he starts firing
the hammer stays where it is so the
hammer the developers are aware of the
hammer and how the hammer functions to
fire each cartridge
what they've misunderstood here is that
well two things really firstly this is a
single action pistol
so pulling the trigger does not [ __ ] the
hammer
and secondly even if it was a double
action trigger
once you fired the first shot the gun
[ __ ] itself
the ejection port is on the wrong side
this is one of those games that suffers
from
left-handed syndrome which as we think
we've discovered
may originate in the counter-strike
series of games another mistake
is that the slide never locks open which
it should
do on this pistol and most other pistols
and we've already seen several examples
of a
jammed slide probably not a super common
malfunction
generally if the cartridge fires all of
that energy has to go somewhere
and generally that's some of it's going
out the front for obvious reasons
and some of it is cycling the slide so
that would have to be
fairly badly rusted shut to not
actually cycle and once you've broke the
rust free
almost certainly it is going to cycle
after that it's a good effort
to introduce deterioration you can
visibly see that the model is
rusted it's not not in a good state
would it complete a full
cycle and properly extract eject and
load the next round quite possibly not
and that would be the sort of
malfunction i would expect to see not
the slide jammed shut
but the slide not moving smoothly enough
to allow the weapon to function
correctly
yeah so once some once the gun
deteriorates to the point where it's
jamming frequently
clearly it lets go in a spectacular
fashion so if you look closely you'll
see that the
the way the model comes apart doesn't
make full sense
there's a big chunk missing out of the
chamber that doesn't look like it's
damaged it looks like it's modeled that
way
the barrel stays on the gun as though it
was a fixed barrel blowback
firearm whereas in fact on this thing
it's a john browning style
tilting barrel and if the gun were to
blow up that's to that extent that the
slide goes flying off pretty sure
the barrel is coming with it i mean it's
uh it's inserted into the slide for one
thing
so the whole thing would just come off
and you'd be left holding
the frame but that said i've never seen
a game model
a catastrophic failure of a firearm at
all so they deserve points for that
so it might seem like heresy but uh
kalashnikov
pattern rifle are also capable of
jamming
an interesting mixture of yanking on the
cocking handle not a bad idea
and tugging on the magazine not going to
achieve anything the magazine on the ak
is locked into the weapon
tapping on it banging on it not gonna do
anything hitting the charging handle
absolutely
you would probably go from yanking on
the charging handle to
what they call mortaring it where you
stick your thumb over the cocking handle
and
bang the butt into the deck and that
gives you the inertia necessary to
overcome
the stock bolt so it looks kind of it's
like action movie level
plausibility of like um i don't know uh
back to the future where
uh the uh the terrorists with his ak
gets a jam and he just
starts sort of slapping the gun in
frustration it's it's better than that
but
um it's not realistically modelled but
again the fact that they have gone to
the effort to try to model weapon
deterioration and failures is
is still pretty impressive
okay so i've got the ak catastrophically
exploding in front of me
it is freeze framed at a point where
what i'm seeing
is our arse facts of the 3d model so
what i think is meant to be the bolt is
actually just a
thin sheet with a handle on the end of
it it should be a solid chunk of metal
or a chunk of it if it's if it's somehow
blown up that badly the top cover has
come off in
in one piece which makes sense but then
underneath you've got this
shelf so above the fire selector um it
should be
a u-shaped bit of metal with the trigger
mechanism sitting inside it
there's none of that interestingly
they've textured that flat
shelf that shouldn't exist and i don't
know why other than i suppose it would
be glaringly obvious if it was just
white
um so superficially doesn't look a
million miles away from some of the
very few occasions i've seen videos of
aks exploding but the bolt is not
modeled as a bolt
it's just a it's basically looks like a
cover and it slides within the 3d model
the ingram model 10 sub machine gun i
like the rate of fire
i quite like the way it's been
implemented we get a good view here of
um
what a deteriorated gun looks like in
the game that kind of
attractive pattern all over it and we
get to see another
another explosion animation and i can
see a nod to a
barrel chamber in the now completely
empty
ejection port like the bolt has somehow
exited the weapon
out of its own ejection port which is
impossible the cocking handle has
disappeared
but the bolt wouldn't magically leave
the gun
maybe that somehow just destroyed the
spring and is stuck in the back of the
receiver i don't know but i have a
feeling it's blown out of the gun
we've now got the fn fal
or something similar to it doesn't look
quite right there's something a little
cursed about this
model the butt stock looks like it's
almost like shark skin or something
the handguard's made out of the same
stuff and it's just like weirdly puffy i
don't know it almost looks upholstered
yeah ironically the mirroring of guns
the flipping of the
model in this means that the otherwise
very ergonomic for its day
fal where you can use the cocking handle
on the left hand side and the ejections
out the right
is not a thing and the right-handed
player
is having to reach over the receiver
like an ak to [ __ ] it which
is the other way around the ak has that
problem so that's just a quirk of the
way they've
mirrored what it looks like is every gun
in the game
so in this detonation animation the
entire front end of the gun has blown
off
don't think is likely barrels are either
threaded in and torqued up to a certain
spec
or they are pressed in an extremely
tight fit meaning that it's more likely
that the back end of the gun the
receiver that's
sheet metal or thin machined metal is
more likely to give way
than the relationship between the barrel
and the barrel extension or the trunnion
or whatever that whatever the barrel is
attached
to so it's not a hugely probable way of
a gun exploding
so an extremely shiny looking desert
eagle that uh the player looks very
proud of and even gives a little
little polish too most of the main
sort of angles on the gun are there you
definitely get the idea
but i think the very very front end
this this that's an iconic muzzle i
don't think they've quite nailed the
look of that
but it is close enough this is
recognizably one they're not doing a
soldier a fortune on it and trying to
make it look like
something completely different the whole
thing is really lethargic as well
so when you shoot this thing you know
you shot it
it pivots up very very quickly uh it
doesn't kind of
slowly come up like clint eastwood
miming the recoil of this magnum which
is what i'm seeing here and the slide
moves faster than your eye can see a
very common mistake
in video game models is that you see a
slide or a bolt
moving as though it's slowed down
right so the the deagle is no more the
deagle has exploded
um and i think that's probably the more
realistic of the
explosion animations i've seen so far in
that it
might happen that way the slide coming
off in this case
the barrel is not in the slide so the
the barrel does stay
fixed to the gun that's part of its
design and it would only be
the slide itself that would come off the
back of the gun
[Music]
it's our old friend the spas 12 or
something close to it
uh we have got more than just a stock
bolt or slide we are seeing
a stove pipe jam a failure to
eject so you see the red plastic hull of
the
12 gauge case stuck in the gun it
appears to be stuck between the face of
the bolt
and the ejection port which could happen
i think and then we see some reasonable
attempts to clear that by yanking on the
cocking handles turning the gun over and
slapping it
not so helpful because if it's
compressed between the bolt and the gun
it's not gonna just drop free when you
slap it you do need to hold the ball
open
and do that to try to get that empty
case out of the gun
this is a slightly cursed rpg 7. the
iron sights are for some reason on the
side of the launch tube they should be
on the
top so this is one of the few weapons in
the game that's not mirrored
but to make up for the fact that it's
not back to front the player is holding
it back to front so he's made the rookie
error
and perhaps that's because his
character's not familiar with the type i
don't know of holding the grips the
wrong way round
the munition itself launches like a
rocket
rather than shooting out of the end like
like a large bullet and then
the rocket motor kicking in so we see
the with the reload
animation we see the warhead being
loaded
it doesn't quite look right they haven't
just got the
warhead portion which is a mistake other
games have made they have got the tail
fin on there
but it doesn't look right it doesn't
have the flick out the long flick out
stabilizing vein fins that should be
there
which should be under a cardboard sheath
to keep them in place
which just blows off when the thing is
fired and i think
i don't think we should have that much
recoil there's virtually no recoil
from an rpg you'll see some if there's
some damage to
either the warhead or the or the
launcher and it's not balanced correctly
you'll see perhaps a bit of movement but
this is modeling recoil more recoil than
we'd expect to see
from a recoilless weapon which is what
the rpg 7 actually is
right uh so we don't luckily for the
player the rpg doesn't explode i guess
they figured that
um that would be that would just take
you out which is true
so instead we see a sort of dodge round
modeled where it kind of plops out of
the end and then fizzles around on the
floor for a bit before exploding
i don't know if that's plausible or not
with it with a pg-7 round
don't think so though because it would
take it's 15 meters downrange before the
motor kicks in
which means it would just sit there as a
dud
shouldn't explode because its nose
hasn't been crushed
and it wouldn't have armed yet so it
should just sit there being a bit of a
risk
as a piece of unexploded ordnance and
you just stick another one in and carry
on i don't think it
could possibly do what it does there but
it makes for some dramatic gameplay as
you try to get the hell away from your
rogue bomb essentially
i think the m79 makes a lot of sense for
an open
relatively open world game like this
giving you a bit of distance
but something to bridge the gap between
an rpg and firearm
we don't seem to be using the sights
it's just a kind of a dead reckoning
point in the vague direction of the
enemy learn your fall of shot kind of
thing
you can tell that the the modelers have
not got
hands on the real one or just aren't
worrying about a level of detail because
the the break open latch
just it stays to one side and then the
gun opens whereas
it works like a shotgun you hold it
against spring pressure and break it
open that way
all right so i was waiting for this to
happen we've got a point blank or that's
not the correct
definition of point blank uh but it's
not the time of the place
firing of an m79 into somebody and it
blows up now it's designed to not do
that it has an arming distance minimum
arming distance for safety purposes
some you know blunt force trauma from a
large bullet hitting you
but not a penetrating wound hopefully
and not an
explosion unless something's gone
horribly wrong this point in gaming
history i don't think that level of uh
realism had been picked up upon just yet
[Music]
okay this thing is weird this looks like
somebody
saw an ar15 once and then tried to make
a video game gun based upon it
the bolt appears to be part of the
receiver
or there's some weird kind of cover
going on that doesn't work like a like
an ar normally would
it's got the m16a1 onwards forward
assist but it's
weirdly tiny and isn't in a position
where i think it would
necessarily work not with this weird
bolt anyway
and then the cocking handle is this
bizarre looking bit of sheet metal
that's also really small yeah very
strange you can see you can see features
of
ar that have been sort of mutated into
something else
so we've got some sort of a failure to
extract and they're removing the
magazine
they're pulling the cocking handle to
the rear so far so good
but then they're pressing the forward
assist which would be counterproductive
because that's a forward assist not a
rearward assist
and would therefore be acting against
you trying to pull the
bolt to the rear to clear the stoppage
but at least they recognized
that the forward assist is useful when
the weapon fails
to function correctly even if they've
combined
the wrong malfunctions
so we've got our good old friend the mp5
sd integrally suppressed mp5
reasonable sound effect actually and the
first thing i'm struck by though is the
use of the iron sights
so the rear drum is turned to the short
range battle site open
v-notch then we are not using that notch
we're looking straight over the top of
it and we're just looking at the front
post
so this is a misunderstanding of how the
iron sights actually work
you don't put the post level with the
site protector
you put it level with the top of the
v-notch in case anyone's wondering
you can in fact reload an mp5 like that
i.e replace the magazine
[ __ ] the weapon it's just difficult to
do because the spring tension from a
full 30 round magazine
bears on the bottom of the bolt and it's
hard to get that magazine to click into
place
it seems a little anemic i think that's
probably a gameplay balance
choice that this is suppressed and
producing
subsonic velocities through the integral
suppressor
therefore they've dialed down the damage
because otherwise you just use this all
the time
[Music]
and i have to pause immediately at the
really not very well
modeled rounds and belt on this
fn minimi they are single
model pieces of brass with no distinct
bullet
and the belt looks like a leather belt
running through the middle of the
cartridges there is
extremely little detail on these which
wouldn't be a problem this is a
relatively old game
if i've just picked up my gun animation
wasn't showing you it
front and center right in your face
drawing attention to
not the best bit of 3d modeling or
texturing i have ever seen
it sort of impresses as a game like
machine gun good
you know realistic rate of fire you can
get the sense of power that
comes with a light machine gun and the
muzzle flash i think is quite well done
for the time
it's not overwhelming but it has that
classic star pattern
we see the the jamming animation
something new
weirdly the top cover pops open and sits
there
and unjamming it consists of smacking it
on the top
until the top cover latches home again
and the gun just magically then starts
firing
there's no attempt to clear the actual
stoppage
there's no cocking and if your top cover
wasn't latching down
just repeatedly smacking it is probably
not the way
to do it you need to lift that thing
open unload
clear the weapon verify that things are
in the right
configuration nothing's damaged and then
essentially load it again and crack on
and hope it works we've got
a left-handed gun because this is how
the game depicts
the guns but a right-handed shooter and
so um he's having to do
very much what um very skilled
left-handed shooters do
and they keep their hand on the on the
wrist and they essentially
lift the gun up work the bolt and then
catch it on the way back down
somehow this clip fed bolt action
repeating rifle is being loaded and
unloaded using clips from
underneath yes with a scope mounted you
can't use the charger
guide to load a clip in you would open
the bolt and
single load rounds with a sniper variant
you do not and cannot load it with clips
from underneath that is a flat floor
plate containing the spring that you
need to force the rounds up
for feeding you can't just jam rounds up
there
well guys you asked for it we gave it to
you the guns of far cry 2
complete with comedy jamming and
exploding
animations which i think was a really
nice effort actually but interesting to
dig into
you can wait for the next episode of
this series uh or you can head over
and or you can head over to the royal
armouries youtube channel and
uh capture series that i've been doing
over there if you'd like to support us
at the museum we've got links up in the
description
otherwise i'll see you again next time
[Music]
[Music]
you